réservé et producteurs de blé de soja et
de maïs
cet été c'est 550 hectares de cultures
poussent de façon inégale
c'est un âne et extrême parce que toutes
les cultures dans notre coin or auront
des difficultés
la sécheresse du printemps a détruit son
blé il a dû faire une réclamation auprès
de la financière agricole du québec pour
pouvoir se met rapidement un autre type
de grain première fois que ça m'arrive
encore de détroit et il est loin d'être
le seul près de 4100 avides dommages ont
été enregistrés auprès de la financière
agricole
mais la vie de plus qu'à pareille date
l'an dernier il ya eu un bon déficit
hydrique un début de saison présentement
c'est en train de se résorber ce soit
que l'ouest de la province le centre
sont encore touchés je dirais montérégie
estrie et en outaouais voir des chats
qui ont le verbe est tout croche décider
des partis tchèques et albédo partie
chaque jour attendu c'était vraiment
spécial avoir cédé plus conscients voire
de poche ou ageris dans l'ouest du pays
les producteurs font face à des
canicules et à des sécheresses extrêmes
je dirais que cette année c'est enfin ça
devient meilleur parce que c'est pas
juste sécheresse de cette année c'est la
sécheresse des tous les autres années
précédentes avec cette année des
compensations financières et des
modifications au programme d'assurance
récolte ont été annoncés dans les
derniers jours par le gouvernement
fédéral mais il en faudra plus dans les
prochaines années pour composer avec les
aléas climatiques
si la production voire descendais parce
qu'on présume que les changements
climatiques sur la production mais la
couverture ne serait pas adéquat de
toute façon donc oui je serais peut-être
pas de certaines modifications au
programme au fil des ans pour pouvoir
les chercher de couverture adéquate pour
alain gervais les prochaines semaines
seront critiques pour son maïs un
agriculteur et permet pas au petit nice
tu là ouf
et tout ce qu'il souhaite c'est de la
pluie ici marc isabelle roche
radio-canada saint denis sur le
richelieu